Traditionally general purpose operating systems have
catered to the needs of throughput oriented
applications, such as databases, and scientific applications.
But now more and more applications, such
as synchronous A/V players, video games, and
so on, need soft real-time guarantees. That
is they are latency sensitive. How do we mix the two kinds of applications
in a general purpose operating system? Also, what are the pain points
in developing complex, multimedia applications that
need such real-time guarantees? How can
they be alleviated? Welcome back. In this module, we will discuss approaches
to addressing these questions. In this
lesson, we will discuss time-sensitive Linux,
an extension of the commodity general
purpose Linux operating system that addresses two
questions. The first question is how
to provide guarantees for real-time applications in
the presence of background throughput oriented
applications, such as databases and so on.
The second question is how to bound
the performance loss of throughput oriented applications
in the presence of latency sensitive applications.